[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Juan Pablo lucumí nuevamente acá para
seguir hablando de la organización
Internacional del trabajo que dijo que
el crecimiento del empleo mundial se va
a reducir a la mitad de este 2023 Así es
Raúl hasta el 1% se espera que se
desacelere el crecimiento del empleo
mundial para 2023 en 2022 el crecimiento
global de empleo fue del 2% y
previamente la organización había
pronosticado una progresión del 1,5%
para este año pero hoy revaló esa
previsión la razón consecuencias por la
guerra en Ucrania la alta inflación
generalizada y los casos de covid que
Todavía siguen golpeando a la segunda
Economía del mundo china Juan Pablo y no
solo el trabajo mundial tendrá un
crecimiento menor sino también la
calidad de los mismos empleos
exactamente así lo dijo Richard samans
el director de investigación de la oit
abro comillas la desaceleración actual
significa que muchos trabajadores
tendrán que aceptar trabajos de menor
calidad a menudo con salarios muy bajos
a veces con horas insuficientes además a
medida que los precios aumentan más
rápido que los ingresos laborales
nominales la crisis del costo de vida
corre el riesgo de empujar a más
personas a la Pobreza cierro comillas y
después de dos años de no realizarse por
la pandemia Ya regresa la reunión anual
del foro económico mundial en davos Raúl
un foro que estará repleto de
discusiones sobre Innovación energía
inversión comercio las futuras
tecnologías empleo salud y clima para el
presidente del foro es importante que
esta vez haya menos charla y más acción
escuchemos
hay tanto en juego que realmente
necesitamos encontrar soluciones a Las
Guerras y los conflictos También tenemos
que asegurarnos de que no entremos en
una recesión y tengamos 10 años de bajo
crecimiento como lo tuvimos en la década
de 1970 veremos más empresas asumiendo
compromisos En áreas que son importantes
como la mejora de las habilidades la
creación de empleo la anticorrupción la
agenda verde el clima o la biodiversidad
entonces Entonces estamos muy
entusiasmados con eso porque es algo que
el mundo necesita menos charla y más
acción
Juan Pablo también se conoció el más
reciente informe de oxfam qué pasó Así
es oxpan es un movimiento mundial de
personas que trabajan juntas para acabar
con la injusticia de la pobreza y este
lunes se conoció su nuevo análisis que
muestra que en términos generales los
las personas ricas van a ser cada vez
más ricas y esto empuja a mayores
niveles de desigualdad según el informe
con datos del 2022 tan solo el 1% de los
ricos acaparó dos tercios de la riqueza
esto es de 2022 también concluye que las
fortunas de los multimillonarios
aumentan en 2.700 millones de dólares al
día incluso cuando al menos 1700
millones de trabajadores ahora están
viviendo en países donde la inflación
supera los salarios Mientras tanto casi
un centenar de empresas de alimentos y
energía duplicó sus ganancias en 2022
básicamente vamos porque nuestra
compañera del equipo económico venir
hablando les está en Davo Suiza y nos
describe los términos generales de lo
que pasa en esta Cumbre con una
temperatura de menos nueve grados
celsius y también con más de 5000
efectivos tanto de la policía como del
ejército desplegados por toda esta zona
inicia entonces hoy el foro económico
mundial en la ciudad alpina de davos
pues hubo quienes desafiaron este
despliegue militar y policial para
manifestarse en contra de este foro
diciendo que no soluciona realmente los
problemas de la sociedad y que sí
incentiva la emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero debido a que muchos de los
asistentes se desplazan hasta aquí en
sus jets privados el tema principal de
esta semana recesión como evitar una
recesión en 2023 también como cooperar
en un mundo fragmentado hoy el día de
hoy se publicó una encuesta entre más de
1000 líderes empresariales que estarán
presentes acá en los que
de ellos afirma que este año
probablemente habrá una recesión Aunque
el 70% también asegura que probablemente
lo peor de la inflación ya pasó y ya
llegó a su pico más alto en 2022 hay más
de 50 jefes de estado invitados a este
foro económico mundial no estarán
presentes ni el presidente de Estados
Unidos ni el presidente de China los dos
países más importantes económicamente
hablando en el mundo cifra del día Juan
Pablo Raúl 250 millones de dólares
cuesta de penthouse el apartamento
Residencial más alto del mundo que
recientemente salió a la venta a Nueva
York el inmueble tiene 23 habitaciones
siete dormitorios ocho baños bibliotecas
sala multimedia salón de baile
ascensores privados y cuatro
maravillosas vistas a la ciudad yo creo
que a usted le gustaría Me encantaría
Pero además de esos 250 millones que
acaba de decir usted creería yo haber
escuchado también una noticia que
solamente pagar el condominio eran como
80 mil dólares mensuales Así que no
solamente esos 250 millones de dólares
Imagínese usted va a costar Juan Pablo
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información de economía luego con